Have you
seen this insane video
of a giant Chinese Coast
Guard boat
ramming into a smaller boat
from the Philippines?
This is just one part of China's
strategy to control
the South China Sea,
which is this really valuable water,
which China claims almost all of.
Now, of course,
no one in the world
recognizes this claim.
And all of China's
neighbors have claims that cut through
China's claim.
That Filipino boat
that was run into by the Chinese
Coast Guard was actually in Filipino
economic waters.
But crucially,
this boat was carrying supplies
to a tiny little island
where the Philippines
has intentionally crashed
an old warship to kind of plant
a flag and claim it as theirs.
And there's a bunch of sailors
who just live out here.
China does not like this.
Hence, going and bullying the supply ship
that's going to refuel them.
China has their own island
building operation,
which they use to put military assets
all over the South China Sea.
And every year
they get more
and more aggressive
in asserting their dominance
over the entire South
China Sea,
which could very easily escalate
into a broader conflict.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.